I wanna make sure we talk about
what you're up to now. Because
this project is so cool.
It's spelled, it's
seasons, but it's S Z N Z.
Yeah. So it's called SZNZ
and there's Spring,
Summer, Autumn, and Winter.
And each one comes out
on the first day of its respective season.
And together they kind of all add up to a
something that feels like a hole.
And each album has a primary emotion.
Spring is optimistic,
Summer is angry
Autumn is anxious, Winter is sad.
Each album has a primary genre.
So, Spring is supposed
to sound kind of like
Island in the Sun.
Summer is supposed to sound
like alternative nineties rock.
And Autumn, which is about to come out
is like dance rock, Franz
Ferdinand, is that sort of thing.
And nineties, sorry, Winter
is like 90 singer songwriter,
Elliot Smith, that kind of thing.
Wow?
That is such a great idea.
That's amazing.
Oh wow, thanks.
That's an amazing idea.
No, it really, I mean.
No one's ever said that.
What? No one's said that?
The three of us just all at the same time,
and we don't agree on anything.
No.
But it's so funny how
everyone in the room just now,
you know, Matt and Sona,
and all of us are just like,
Oh, that's just awesome.
What a great idea.
That really is.
Now what inspired you?
Well, it all started with Dropbox because,
What?
Beethoven said the same thing.
(everyone laughing)
I just, every day, I just write
and I don't think about
where a song is gonna go.
I don't, I don't.
It's just whatever sounds
cool to me in the moment.
But because of Dropbox,
I would just sort them into
these different folders
and, Well, this sounds
kind of like Dance Rock,
so I'll put it in this folder,
or this one sounds like
nineties singer song writer.
I'll put it over here.
And everything was just all nice
and neatly sorted and
everything had a home.
And I didn't have to worry about,
well, we're making this
kind of album this year,
so everything has to
fit a particular sound.
It just went to whatever
folder it actually belonged in.
And then I started thinking like,
well, what can I do with all this?
How can I tie it together?
Or should I make four
different albums or what?
And somehow I remembered
of all these four seasons
and well there's four seasons
and yeah, maybe we can
kind of tie it together
under that umbrella.
And so you released one, is
the whole project done now,
and you're just waiting to
release them in time or no?
We're kind of it in real time.
So like, we're like, we
just turned in Autumn
and it's gonna come out obviously,
what is it, September 21st?
Yeah. So it's a very last minute.
And for the fans, it's been
fun to watch it all happen
in real time.
Watch Weezer scramble
to meet the deadlines.
Did you find that you were angry
when you were making Summer?
I was definitely anxious
when I was making Autumn.
(everyone laughing)
No. Yeah, I did.
I did feel, maybe I just noticing it
because it was on my mind, but I have felt
those emotions as I was making each album.
I'm a little worried about Winter now.
Yeah. You're gonna get sad.
Yeah.
Yeah. We're just starting that one now.
I could come by with
like an ice cream cake.
Oh no.
What?
But I need to be sad.
Yeah.
With an ice cream cake.
Well, it's not gonna be a good,
Here's the thing,
it's not gonna be a good ice cream cake.
Oh, okay.
Yeah.
It'll just make him more sad.
Yeah. And it's gonna
say, I hate you on it.
That's a terrible idea.
Well, it's gonna make him sad.
He didn't let me finish.
God, these guys jump in
whenever I think I have
a really good idea.
They totally screw with me.
It's not right.